foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar enabling
fully automated NGS sample preparation
using digital microfluidics I'm archana
the product manager for Miro canvas and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
this webinar is brought to you by
miraculous to learn more about us visit
miraculous.com
we encourage you to participate by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so just
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send at the end of the
presentation we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for also
please submit any technical issues here
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
I'd like to introduce our two speakers
for today
Dr Fay Christo Lulu is the co-founder
and chief scientific officer at
miraculous she completed her PhD degree
at the European molecular biology
laboratory in Heidelberg Germany her
work in RNA biology and evolutionary
developmental biology has been published
in nature cell and science
her entrepreneurial and scientific
contributions have been awarded by
numerous International organizations
including the first prize at The sfee
Innovation project the healthcare
Technology reviews top 25 women leaders
in biotechnology the Endeavor Global
Network as Endeavor Greece's third
female entrepreneur and Fortune Greece's
40 under 40.
Dr Jonathan Levine is the senior
director of assay development at
interpace biosciences and will also be
the Medical Science liaison for the GI
team he earned his PhD from the
University of Maryland medicine and
biochemistry and molecular biology
Dr Levine completed his MBA at Johns
Hopkins with the Dual focus in
Healthcare Management and finance he has
worked in the genomic crispr metabolomic
and diagnostic markets at Agilent
metabolon and twist bioscience before
joining interpace it is great to have
both of you here okay you may now begin
your presentation
thank you for the introduction
welcome everyone from my side too
uh zartana mentioned I'll be talking
about how our product is enabling fully
automated NGS sample preparation and how
digital microfluidics technology is
powering all of that
at miraculous our mission is to advance
science and improve lives faster
together
and I'll start with a quick introduction
to the company that was founded in 2015
miraculous is venture-backed and we're
headquartered in San Francisco we have a
team that is very Multicultural and
diverse and also equally large more than
20 languages spoken in the in the
company at the moment and equally large
IP portfolio with more than 40 patent
applications eight of which are already
issued today
we want to help scientists reimagine
automation which today looks a lot like
how our transit system works the transit
system requires a lot of people that use
it large budgets and then also Riders
who go to the same destination
and then planning that and once it is
planned with all this heavy and
expensive infrastructure it is very uh
inflexible to change
so we want to bring a new solution to
the table that now suddenly makes
automation accessible for any sample at
any moment
it doesn't require waiting to batch
samples so that they can be processed in
a cost-effective And Timely fashion and
also doesn't need a large budget and
specialized infrastructure to to host
this type of solution
our automation vision is very simple and
flexible in switching protocols within
few minutes and also modifying protocols
making it customized to the needs of
each scientist and lastly the user
friendliness wind vision is going to
enable anyone with minimal training to
enjoy the benefits of automation
earlier this year we announced the
commercial launch of our product the
mural canvas and here you see that it's
a compact versatile personal digital
microfluidic system for lab and for
protocol automation
it comes together with software that
allows the protocols to be
designed and executed and also has a
consumable cartridge that has that is
electronics free and disposable
we have tested the mirror canvas with a
wide range of kits and reagents and have
been effective at using it without any
problems so that makes our technology
agnostic to any kit and reagent and we
have also read the output libraries with
four different sequencing Technologies
so far and the list is going to keep
growing later in the slide we will
review results from all of these four
different sequencing Technologies
so how does it work uh neurotechnology
utilizes electromechanical forces that
actuate droplets on an open array of
electrodes and these electrodes are
insulated as you see in the schematic on
the right and we do not require any
immersion in oil or any direct contact
of the droplets to our Electronics so in
this cross-section schematic that you
see on the right the droplet as you can
notice is always sandwiched between two
hydrophobic layers and that allows it to
easily slide when we apply voltage
underneath in uniquely controlled
electrodes and the other thing to notice
is that the droplets are always
surrounded by air so hence why no no
need for oil immersion
now you see in the mirror canvas with
the lid open in this image there's a lot
of sophistication under the hood
um you see the first thing to notice is
the electrode open array so that is
permanently part of the instrument and
the cartridge hence is electronics free
on the right under this electrode a bed
of electrodes there are heaters and
coolers for them and then also for
magnets and together with other system
functionalities we can enable all of the
lists that you see on the left so we can
have this fencing of droplets we can
merge droplets or we can mix them and
here the mixing can be very gentle in a
controlled fashion or rigor vigorous
like when you use a pipet we can
incubate above and below room
temperature in in the heaters and
coolers we can thermal cycle we can do
as many PCR Cycles as the protocols
require
and then we can engage magnets and
Achieve big cleanups so wash beads with
different buffers elude from beads and
finally it's possible to interface uh
the digital microfluidic environment
with traditional Channel physics and
that has many advantages especially one
I mentioned in the vigorous mixing
abilities which are not typical of other
microfluidic systems so
one thing to to underline here is that
the mirror canvas is the only digital
microfluidic system out there that
actually allows full integration of any
protocol steps including PCR and beat
cleanups in the same contained cartridge
and this is a cartridge I already said
it's Electronics free and it's
disposable at the end of the run after
the product library is collected it can
go
um we see it here on the left
in its key component as a breakdown and
you can notice how there are three
reservoirs in these reservoirs we load
all of the buffers that get uh
used more than once in a protocol for
example ethanol for washes or wash
buffers for heated post hybridization
washes or even water or trees and and
then 12 individual inlets where we load
the exact volumes of the master mixes
and reagents that are needed in every
step in the protocol that's where we
also load the sample and that's also
where we recover at the end of the run
the product Library
now it's important to see how the
droplets are actually sandwiched between
the the cartridge body in Gray and this
uh film in the bottom so everything is
contained which makes the mirac
cartridge uh a very secure system even
though we generate amplicons for some
application from PCR cycling uh from
cross-contamination so from one
experiment to another we have tested and
there's no no chance for
cross-contamination to happen as
everything is securely contained in the
cartridge
so what happens when you press Start we
just saw a DNA droplet merge with a
reaction Master mix and then after
incubating merge with Magnetic particles
that eventually get pelleted when we
engage in magnet underneath and then we
follow with bead cleanups and and
removing the super native on the left we
see individual droplets controlled in
any direction of the open array of
electrodes
foreign
we have designed the mirror canvas so
that it's easy to use effectively
allowing us to transition from the image
most of us are familiar with in the left
multi-page protocols having to read them
in detail making sure that while we
execute the the experiment we check that
all of the steps are done properly to
The Right Use case where we just click
through some images in the screen and
load under instruction under direction
of the system the right reagent in the
right location and start the Run
foreign
the mural canvas so that it's
self-installable
you see here images from the homes of
our team members at the start of the
pandemic they took Mira canvas which is
portable at home and could carry on the
progress that we're making at the time
thanks to the system's portability
we have demonstrated a number of
protocols that can reproducibly be ran
on Memorial canvas and here you see the
list and specifically how there is they
serve applications in both whole genome
sequencing and whole exome sequencing
uh and within whole genome sequencing
the top three are actually protocols
used for long read sequencing such as
packed bio smart Grill prep version 3 as
the latest by pack bio the previous
version the version two and also the
only 1D ligation kit all of these are
for long grid sequencing and then below
we have the short read sequencing
protocols such as mural whole genome
sequencing pcr3 that one takes
mechanically shared DNA as input
and then the Illumina DNA PCR free prep
kit for Rapid hold genome sequencing
that receives intact DNA as input and
segmentation based protocol uh the
watchmaker DNA Library prep kit with
fragmentation but also receives intact
DNA and
fragmentation based protocol
and for whole election there is a
library The Twist Library preparation
and somatic fragmentation kit that
protocol actually has PCR cycling
ranging from as low as eight all the way
to more than 16 cycles for specific
panels and then for the actual Target
enrichment using hybridization capture
we have the demonstrated results in the
twist human core exome fast
hybridization Target enrichment kit and
also the Adrian xdhs 2 and the IDT
action kicks and these last two are
coming soon for beta testing in the
bottom you see some snapshots of the
application notes we have released and
they're available on our website upon
request to be sent to you
so the list will just walk through the
common denominator for all these
protocols even though they range from
duration and to complexity to other
parameters that need special caution the
common denominator when using the mirror
canvas is that they take 15 minutes of
active engagement maximum 15 minutes of
active engagement with the system to
just load the required reagents and
press start the run and the rest is true
walk away automation you only return to
collect the product library that is
sequence ready
and another important aspect of using
digital microfluidics as a technology is
that because it's microfluidic it also
allows to reduce volume reagents and for
some applications we have achieved that
for as low as 75 for as high as 75
reagent savings which of course makes
the processes most cost effective
so how do our customers use the canvas
well there is definitely a lot of
activity in the long read sequencing
space the the throughput of the system
and the sequencers are a great match and
also again the gentle handling of of
droplets in the mirror canvas ensure
that the integrity and the length of
high molecular weight DNA are maintained
throughout multi-step protocols that
require special attention in some steps
so essentially assuring our customers
that at the end the the wheel get the
longest possible reads out of their
sequencing round
we also have customers and you'll hear
from one of them uh Dr Levine later in
this webinar uh who used the canvas for
very lengthy and tedious multi-step
protocols that require experts hands to
execute such as hybridization and
capture for Target enrichment
applications in Exum or Gene panels and
there the chemistry actually allows to
pull more than one libraries and then
Reach In Parallel out of all of the
different samples in one cartridge and
mirror canvas around
and then another very interesting area
where the real canvas is an excellent
fit is in faster and around applications
because it is a system waiting them
they're idle until the process enters
the lab and it's readily available to
start automation immediately of the
library preparation in these types of
applications the speed is of essence and
of course the quality and reliability of
automation is very important and that's
where real canvas can contribute
so now that we know how the technology
works and what areas it could be applied
on we can review some data together
generated using the canvas all of the
data we will walk through are actually
from 100 fully automated runs and the
duration for each of the protocols as I
mentioned earlier will vary between for
the fastest two hours all the way to
five and a half hours for the most
complex ones
so here we review first whole genome
sequencing data from longer sequencing
Technologies starting with pack bio
here we actually use the latest key the
smart build prep version 3 and you see
on the left figure uh a representative
redistribution profile of a
representative mural canvas Library
for this kit actually allows lower input
of DNA so we went with as well as one
microgram of na24 385 in this experiment
and another advantage of this new kit is
that it consolidates all of the library
purification steps in one integrated
workflow so relying on bit based
selection so all of the steps were
conducted in the mirror canvas there was
no need for external instrumentation
here the library at the end was sequence
ready
and on the right table you can see the
the standard um run metrics after the
sequencing is over so Hi-Fi reads
um the read length and and the the
quality of the reads all at the expected
levels
and now about the content of these
libraries what could be read in there so
uh conducting a structural variant
analysis to see what was detectable on
the right table you can see that we
could identify the same numbers of
structural variants for mural canvas
libraries as as well as manual
representative Library so same number of
variants same types of variants so we
see that there are deletions
duplications insertions
in inversions translocations all there
and then on the left they even have the
same distribution When comparing uh the
mirror canvas libraries to manual so
essentially we're mirroring uh what was
done in the hands of an expert uh money
using the canvas
here we know that the smart build prep
kit can also be applied for sequencing
shorter input material for example in
microbiome sequencing uh amplicon can be
the input to to this Library preparation
method and we wanted to test whether
with small modifications to our script
really minor modifications we we could
actually support these types of
applications so we mocked after using a
linearized plasmid instead of actual
amplicon in this particular example and
you can see on the table comparing to
manual how the mirror canvas was
consistently yielding
a sufficient library to proceed with
sequencing and then running these
Library product libraries of our model
uh and comparing the manual uh to mural
canvas we get the same
electrophyograms from from tape station
with the Peaks at matching positions and
and intensity so we're very excited with
this preliminary results in in the
thought that we can be serving a new
application that uses pack biosequencers
for Oxford nanopore here we use the 1D
ligation kit and we were able to reduce
volumes all the way down to one-fourth
of what the kit recommends and generate
quality results
so we're looking at
um the the distribution redistribution
profiles of manual on the left and
mirror canvas on the right that look
very uh similar and uh here we used one
microgram of designobionics high
molecular weight DNA standard this is a
standard with a microbial Community mock
composition
so we get the same results between
manual and real canvas in terms of
redistribution profiles and then when
inspecting the key sequencing metrics
such as the read length the read quality
and the n50 score we also are within the
same range of values that are obtained
from from manual libraries when compared
to mirror cameras
again in terms of content what can be
found after we read these libraries we
find we could identify all of the mock
community members of this microbial
sample and that those include microbial
and one yeast species so you see
comparing the list of manual to the list
of neural canvas that they're exactly
the same
and recently uh in collaboration with a
lab that has mastered the difficult
protocol of actually yielding libraries
for Ultra long sequencing that requires
a lot of expertise and care and
attention in several steps of the one
delegation kit we we work together and
modified our scripts so that we can
serve this type of labs with libraries
that can be destined for Ultra long
sequencing and we used in this
particular example isolated DNA High
molecular weight DNA from hec293 cells
and treated the DNA with the short read
Eliminator kit and you see that we get a
redistribution profile with an n50 score
close to 78 KB which of course now can
serve this type of application so we're
very excited about this and we'll be
releasing a script to the community soon
earlier I mentioned how the mirror
canvas is portable and by uh referring
to that it really means it can actually
be carried in a backpack as you see here
on the left images and on the right is
one of our customers who literally took
the mirror canvas to the field outside
the lab because that's their region of
interest and they wanted to conduct in
situ sequencing which has happened
before but with the mirror canvas for
the first time we enabled in situ
Library preparation followed by
Institute sequencing so essentially
processing the sample at the region of
interest
and in this specific example you see how
the mirror canvas was actually powered
by solar fed batteries so that's also a
very exciting enablement of the
technology
now let's look at some whole genome
sequencing a short read data
and here we have used the mirror pcr3
whole genome sequencing kit and tested a
range of inputs of na12 h7a DNA
starting at 100 nanograms and going all
the way up to 500 nanograms and it was
possible to reproducible yield libraries
that outperformed those generated using
traditional liquid handlers at the
genome Center large genome Center
uh whose clinical genome
Criterion is that 95 of bases are above
our 20x coverage as you can see on the
figure in the left with a green dotted
line so uh in the x-axis we have the the
total sequence basis that enable that so
you can see that the blue dots which
depict individual mural canvas libraries
require less sequencing compared to the
regression curve and where it intersects
the green dotted line which represents
the traditionally good handling
libraries that the genome Center
generated and then for another important
sequencing metric the percent of
heterozygous sleep sensitivity we
consistently outperformed uh in real
canvas libraries the the traditional
liquid handling libraries as well
Now using the list of the input from
that same kit 100 nanograms we also
sequence the mirror pcr3 libraries using
the latest
um recently released element sequencer
the ability
and in this table we see the the results
from a from comparing manual to New York
canvas these are standard key sequencing
metrics and uh especially on the right
we see how it is possible to deliver a
conflict and variant calling with these
F1 scores for Snips and indels that look
uh very very good and then in the bottom
plot we got a near unbiased coverage
across the GC content of the data set so
that's also for both manual in red and
mirror canvas libraries in in view
we have demonstrated the applicability
of your canvas for Rapid hold genome
sequencing using the Illumina DNA prep
PCR free kit and here in in this table
you see the results sequencing results
and so everything is sub-sampled to 40x
coverage comparing the manual to mirror
canvas runs across an input of DNA from
range from 50 nanograms all the way to
500 and so across Matrix we see very
comparable
numbers essentially matching uh the
bench the manual experiments
um and despite dropping the input amount
uh for example in terms of the percent
of bases at 20x we get uh the same
readout uh and again for this specific
application what matters the most is
confident variant calling and you see
that with the F1 scores for both single
nucleotide variants and insertion
installations we can definitely deliver
that
now results on whole exome sequencing
this application is unique in the sense
that the protocols require PCR cycling
and as I mentioned earlier depends on
the panel for for x and because b as few
as eight cycles for small Gene panels it
can be more than 16 PCR cycles and you
will hear about an application of this
kind in the talk later here this
requirement is what we use to design
mural canvas so that it is possible to
conduct protocols protocol automation
where there are PCR steps so
you can see here the results from twist
human core exome fast hybridization
Target enrichment and here we used
individual libraries that were enriched
through hybridization and capture using
this kit and in each of the figures we
reflect one of the important sequencing
metrics percent duplicates percent on
target the fold 80 score and then the
depth of coverage at both 20x and 30X
and in in Gray we have replicate the bar
the gray bars reflect replicate runs
that are manual and the blue bars
replicate Rams in your canvas so you see
the results are matching we we could
match the on your canvas libraries the
same sequencing performance as on manual
libraries in the hands of experts
we repeated the same experiment and this
time around uh pulled eight libraries
into a single cartridge and conducted
one mural canvas run comparing to one
pulled manual run and in the table again
we have the key Target enrichment
metrics of relevance and how they
compare between manual and real canvas
and we see that we are within the same
ranges and and have quality libraries
here too and especially when visualizing
the uh the the reads that confidently
map to targeted regions of the exome and
we have here a specific example for egfr
exons 2 to 10. it is possible to deliver
confident variant calling if we focus on
the fourth axon which is in the middle
um we off of the tracks uh the most
isolated Peaks if we compare the two top
tracks which are manual to the two
bottom tracks that are mural canvas runs
we see the same heterozygous variant
example and this is of course only one
representative Gene and we could uh we
have data from for more
uh as part of a large reliability study
we also wanted to know what is the
interoperator and inter-system
variability when conducting 70 action
preparations using neural canvas so
again here we list the two most
important Target enrichment metrics the
30X coverage and default 80 score in box
plots across operators comparing manual
runs which are depicted in black dots to
mirror canvas runs in shades of blue and
shapes different shapes reflecting
different instruments used and you can
see that everything every mirror canvas
run is within the same range as the
manual runs in the hands of different
operators and here we're looking at
eight operators and 14 different
instruments
we went through quite a few uh results
so to recap we have several protocols uh
automated and ready to go for both
holding them sequencing and how lexim
sequencing applications in whole genome
sequencing we serve both long read and
short read uh sequencers we have
reviewed together results from ngi
sequencing today that demonstrate high
quality performance of the libraries
generated on mural canvas uh the mirror
canvas allows to reduce reagent volumes
from the current providers you have for
some of the protocols that we offer and
it also allows to flexibly switch from
one protocol to another literally at the
Press of a button and also to flexibly
modify the protocols that we offer with
modifications for example the PCR cycles
and steps in the protocol where you have
to customize for your needs and again
we'll hear a application of that in the
next talk
finally using this type of automation
minimizes a plastic teeth usage and is
also great for the environment
our vision at miraculous is to make the
most complex protocols easy and
accessible to scientists everywhere
and we would love to hear from you what
applications from the ones were
presented would serve your needs in your
lab and also what what else we need to
add to that list of protocols that keeps
growing thank you for your attention
foreign
thank you so much for sharing Faye I'd
like to now welcome Jonathan you may now
begin your presentation
thank you so much and again fantastic
presentation fact so today I'll be
starting uh my presentation going over
some data that we produced in the lab
primarily MGS data or only NGS data for
risk stratification for cancer
so let's begin shall we
okay
but first is to get started off this is
a rune he is a member of the assay
development team at Enterprise and most
if not all of the work he has done with
his own very hands or with miraculous
instrumentation but a little background
about interface and who we are actually
ruins one of those tenured people
we were established in 2014 or publicly
traded company where he we operated
clear cap lab we have two sites one in
New Jersey where our headquarters is and
then our Diagnostic lab in Pittsburgh
and really we have two core businesses
our endocrine business and our GI
business and molecular testing is our
bread and butter and when I joined
interpace I kept thinking to myself what
a great name right with the mission of
providing Health Care Providers with the
ability to avoid unneeded surgeries
and also assess risk overall for cancer
and with that name interface like in our
thinking like inter which is the between
or connecting and pace which could be uh
the pace of movement or the rate of
movement or even a step by connecting
the steps so to speak in the in the road
of Diagnostic and risk stratification
ironically though
uh that was not the case the the company
is actually named for a street called
inner Pace Parkway which connects of
course different streets and actually
it's ironic because when it comes to
what I do and what we do at interpace
it's constantly thinking about the road
the road map for product development the
roadmap for patients
and ironically if you look at our road
uh interpace Parkway on the bottom right
where that Google sign is that's
actually where our office is in that
area but as you can see if you continue
on the road there's there's other
Healthcare companies and pharmaceutical
companies so it kind of makes sense
we're upstream or up road so to speak of
the pharmaceutical companies because we
do focus on diagnostics so one road is
specifically focused on our GI business
where we have our fluid chemistry which
is branded 0.2 because it only requires
200 microliters so 0.2 CA or point of
glucose
um and then of course we have our
molecular stratification our integrated
molecular assay and that's called
pankogen and it really is to help
stratify risk for pancreatic cysts
the other road that we have is our
endocrine road which is specific
specifically for thyroid and we have
firemere and hygienics with thyra mirror
being a mRNA classifier antigenics being
an NGS panel
and these are the two roads that we're
always thinking about
uh and on the road for for thyroid
there's a lot of different
tools and methodologies for Diagnostics
it's a high incidence a lot of nodules
are found accidentally
uh and again what we really make our
bread and butter is the molecular
testing ax point
inside of the thyroid
Market or industry or or discipline
the risk stratification is so important
that the community ATA has Bethesda
classifications and those
classifications correlate to risk
however
elucidation of those risks sometimes
goes beyond what is cytologically
capable
as such you'll see here when you have a
Bethesda 3 you'll have a 60 to 30 risk
of malignancy versus the Bethesda 4
which is a 10 to 40 percent
versus the Bethesda 5 which is 45 to 75
molecular testing and the way that we
help stratify helps sir helps Physicians
but also patients of course understand
that risk and do you need surgery maybe
you want a Hemi uh thyroidectomy versus
a full thyroidectomy or perhaps you wait
on surgery these are the types of
decisions that Physicians and patients
have to consider all the time
that being said when you look at thyroid
you can see there it's the second Arrow
where the bottom Arrow you can see the
survival rate is actually quite High
which is great news for those who have
this condition however the other Road
Less Traveled unfortunately is the
pancragen or pancreas sorry and as you
can see it has a very very high
mortality rate with a very low survival
window
and why is that
well if you look at the statistics most
of the
obviously most of the patients who
survive the longest are those who've
been diagnosed when it is localized when
it is early in the metastasized however
the actual funding or diagnosis or
identification of say cancer is not
usually localized as you can see that's
about 12 percent with a majority usually
being diagnosed in the distant or
Regional huh
this of course leads to the need for
earlier detection more markers so on and
so forth
and again just to put this in
perspective pancreatic cancer although
it is not one of the highest of new
incidents or new cases it is still one
of the deadliest and this it is graphic
here you can see it's Fourth it's
actually I believe moving up to third or
second
and part of the reason for that is when
you look at the United States population
and parts of the global population as
well although smoking is going down
diabetes and obesity are going up
and ironically the highest risk
indicator for those getting pancreatic
cancer would be chronic pancreatitis
which of course is partly induced by
obesity and diabetes as well so it's
really a an ongoing problem that's only
going to get worse
and you can see here it's expected to be
the second leading cause of deaths in
the in the cancer space in the years to
come
also the median age is 72 and that's not
really that old anymore once upon a time
that might have been considered old but
in today's world it's not considered
that old anymore so when you think about
all these different things it's a bit of
a bumpy road right so when we're we're
going on this road we're constantly
thinking about things on how to make it
better better for the patients our
patients are always in the forethought
um our physicians and then of course the
road for the product map right the
product roadmap so to speak how do we
make it more efficient faster turnaround
less hands time
um less plastic environmentally friendly
uh obviously cost but not like costs
when it comes to the the cost of the
reagent but the the cost of time and
then of course space has its own cost
um do you have the space can you scale
up can you not scale up so when you deal
with these type of problems on these
bumpy roads it's nice to have some
friends so and to that back in may we
have the formal
um press release where we we let
everyone know that we were working with
miraculous to automate the NGS pathway
that we use which is a Twist bioscience
hybridization technique
now just to some quick Basics I want to
just touch on before we go down this
road
the hybridization methodology is a
little bit different than an ampicon
method when you're enriching and
basically I like the hook analogy and
people always use the hook analogy like
you're fishing and
it's hooked but it's also hook and key
because you are using specific baits to
pull out the DNA of Interest now you can
make different sizes particularly with
hybridization you can have very large
panels exons which which you've seen on
during face talk but also paying cancers
which are mid-size panels and then
smaller Focus panels we'll be talking
about a focus panel today which means
when you look at the sequencing metrics
the card metrics you you expect to hire
off Target you expect
lower uniformity in some cases and then
for our particular things because this
is multi-ohmic we'll be doing an RNA
enrichment along with our genomics some
of the metrics aren't necessarily as
telling as they would like to be
that said
when you have your workflow for your
enrichment there's the conventional
methodology which is standard
hybridization which is usually overnight
and now
um more and more companies are coming
out with a fast hybridization and that
is what is actually run on the mirror
canvas which is the fast hybridization
both have their place
um usually you'll get the best
sequencing metrics using a standard
hybridization overnight and fast hype
can reach uh comparable results but at
the end of the day it also depends on
what you need from your data do you need
actionability do you need an answer
versus trying to optimize recurrency
through sequencing metrics so we
actually did that we took our small
Focus panel and did a direct comparison
with standard hybridization and it was
done manually
versus the fast hybridization on the
mirror canvas
and as you can see here this is our off
Target or percent off Target you can
actually see the mirror canvas
outperforms in some cases the standard
overnight and done manually now again
this is more of a ballpark approximation
because of the RNA that's in there
that's not necessarily accounted for but
it produces comparable results and
results that in turn just as good and in
this case it would seem arguably better
now this could also be due to
temperatures
um within the settings of the mirror
canvas which again are adjustable and
then for full transparency if you were
doing off bait which again is the
the nucleic acids that are away from the
probe that are not on the probe and
again you add padding certain bases off
of the probe to help with that statistic
it would appear that the standard
hybridization is slightly better than
that of the fast hybridization again
these results are not unexpected and
again but the real question is great we
have these sequencing metrics we can
optimize them that's wonderful
what does it mean from an actual
actionability perspective so when we
look at the data and on the left in the
left-hand column those are different
samples
and then one column you'll have the
manual standard hybridization and these
were both done at eight plexes
and for those of you who don't know an
apex is when you take eight samples and
you hybridize the probes and you
hybridize all eight samples with that
one set of ropes so one uh tube of
reaction and that's because the samples
are already barcoded that you're able to
do that
now we also have the same eight Plex
with the fast time
and you can see we're getting comparable
answers
um for the one sample you see a t53
mutation with a very similar
frequency a variant and then again with
the B ref and hrefs again you're seeing
it you're seeing a comparable frequency
of mutation that's great that's exactly
what you want and this is done in an
apex wonderful right however
where does this lead us with samples
right if everything was so easy so it is
that time of year uh for those of you
who are at least on the East Coast uh
where we have apples and and just like
when you get a bushel of apples we're a
Diagnostic lab we don't really choose
the samples we get we get what we get
and the old expression goes
um One Bad Apple can ruin a bunch
ironically
as you can see here there are no bad
apples inside those are my boys picking
out good apples and we actually had a
problem because believe it or not
sometimes we actually get very good
quality samples and they spoil the bunch
so let me explain that
as you can see here on this slide we
have on the left hand side samples that
are derived from slides and on the right
hand side samples that are fnas fine
needle aspirations
you can see the quality of the slides
are more comparable with each other even
though they're lower quality overall
where the FNA is again similar quality
but then you have that one that one
sample just it's a good seed what can I
tell you it's just a good apple
and what happens is because the quality
of the DNA is so much better it
indirectly seems to be just sucking up
all the sequencing weeds
what that does is it kind of robs Peter
to pay Pawn away where it's taking Reeds
from samples that matter not samples
that matter it's taking reach from other
samples in the same sequencing batch so
you're not always getting the depth that
you need now again as I told you we're
always thinking about the road the
product roadmap the patient's road to
um hopefully better health and one of
the experiments that we did try is
actually doing an aplex and you can see
here on the left and right those are the
slides
but we also tried doing the higher Plex
now there are multiple reasons why we
tried
um and what was really interesting about
that is you could see there on the on
the top figure
uh just above 20 there's that one sample
just sucking up 20 of the over 20 of the
reads but when we combine them as a 24
Plex and then ran them on one sequencing
sample you see that actually it's it
drops significantly from that that
higher number that's around that 15 ish
number so it's not taking as many reads
so basically what we're saying or what
we saw in this anomaly because it's
contrary to what you would think because
normally a lower Plex yields better data
is that because the higher Plex
uh has more samples in it for some
reason it is pulling down that one good
sample basically allowing the
heterogeneity in the sample type to be
mitigated a little bit better so we
wanted to test this right this is a
unique finding at least for us and we
created an experiment where we had eight
samples and we made uh three Library
perhaps for each sample and we ran them
as either an apex a 16 Plex or 24 plus
we normalized everything including the
amount of DNA going in because we wanted
to ensure a genomic equivalence or equal
and not um a factor that could be
pointed to as a as a difference for why
sample data might be different
and what we found was was again the the
effect maintained
so on the top there you have a 24 Plex
and an eight Plex and that's the
standard hybridization done manually and
just underneath of it you have the
miraculous fast hybridization and what
you see is the distribution of the reads
per sample
fever the higher Plex being more uniform
meaning the samples each get the same
amount of sequencing versus the more
Dynamic amount of sequencing per sample
that you see with the e-plex
which is not only great news for dealing
with a variety of sample types but also
provides us with a great utility with
veneer canvas because now while it's
once could handle eight samples can now
handle 24.
and again this is just another
representation just showing the same
thing more uniform reaps per sample and
you can see here each each square with
inside of this graph is one sample
and you can see that the green that's
when it was a 24 Plex and done in
batches
um and versus an apex and you can see uh
the distributions of the secret thing
and really what you want to pay
attention to is the gap in the
percentage between a red a one sample
and a red and another and a green in one
sample and a Greener of another because
the amount of this because the amount of
SQL sync is being more evenly
distributed and then pulled down the
amount of difference between the
sequences is also less meaning again
you're getting a more uniform response
this just validating the data we saw
earlier
now that we've done that we want to take
the next step do a direct comparison to
manual versus narrow canvas and here you
see these are the same samples and the
dark green is the standard hybridization
and the light green is the mirror canvas
and as you can see they're comparable
some samples are better with the mirror
canvas some better and again with the
mirror canvas and fast time
and others were better with the standard
hybridization done manually but again
comparable results and again when you
just another look at this is when you
break it down by sample and then done in
triplicate you can also see a very
similar Distribution on these triple
kits as well and again each each square
is one sample and done in triple kit so
you can see this that distribution is is
nice and tight so but again sequencing
metrics are great what does that mean
do you see an effect on the the data
Downstream and the answer is not really
so here we have an experiment where we
have an eight Plex standard High
so this should produce the best
sequencing quality uh in this experiment
then we have a 24 Plex with the fast
hybridization of an American again the
concentration is constant of 187
nanograms so similar identical genomic
equivalents
and this is our next seat
and when you look at the data you will
see that different samples will produce
similar results you're able to see the
same mutations in very close frequency
of the variant so for instance you saw
here t53 at 16.09 and you're going to
see it at 15.39 and again this is just a
representation of some samples but again
comparable data actionable data and with
the mirror canvas it's all hands-off
time you don't have to sit and babysit
or actually do the pipetting
and then just another look from the
experiment that we showed you earlier
where we did the eight samples and
triple kit so you could do the Apex
versus the 16 Plex versus the 24 Plex
you could see a similar result here you
have the
um the miraculous mirror canvas on the
right hand side versus the standard
manual hybridization same amount of
input and again you're seeing comparable
results you do have this one here where
it doesn't show up on the mirror canvas
and it does show here but that's more a
factor of the fact there wasn't enough
sequencing depth
um and now you can see the number of
reads which is too low for the variance
in which we were willing to call so
that's not necessarily a judgment on on
the instrument or the methodology that's
more of the fact that deeper sequencing
was needed overall for that
and then here we have the 24 Plex and
you see once again but in the reverse
you have the standard High missing one
where the mirror canvas picked it off
and again that's just a emblematic and
not enough sequencing for that one that
one sample but again the takeaway
message comparable actionable results
similar mutations found at a similar
frequency so that's really what the
takeaway is so
why do we think we see this this is
something we've done internally as the
Arun Levine effect what we believe is
going on is
instead of it being linear where the
more you Plex the lower the quality of
data it's probably a bit more gaussian
and the reason we say that is what
happens is you have this you have your
DNA here and the red is representing off
Target and the green Is On Target high
quality and then you have your probes of
interest hybridizing and pulling down
and you have that one good quality data
um piece of DNA or sample in that case
here is an example of where you add more
samples that are of lower quality
however they have like more cream
targets so even though the overall
quality of that one sample might be
lower than than that of the really good
sample by adding enough of the lower
quality samples there's still enough
DNA that is good enough to hybridize
that would out compete an off Targets in
there in red almost like a competitive
inhibition
and this is not like I said it's not
linear I believe it's gaussian there is
a Tipping Point you can't just Plex
forever and think you can keep going up
and you're going to get these good
results at some point it will there are
diminishing returns and a big part of
that has to do with your design of your
panel the size of your panel which we
talked about earlier and the tuning of
the temperatures which again you can do
both manually and within your canvas so
this is to take away from this
um why it matters
uh you have democratization through high
for for high throughput NGS with this
instrumentation you can do an 8 to 24
Plex meaning with a couple of
instruments you could have a very high
throughput lab or you could be a very
flexible app because sometimes you get
eight in sometimes you might get 40 in
you can and that comes back to how well
you tune your your plexing
there's no longer a need for very large
instrumentation spaces is is very
valuable to us as it is the most and
this this little instrument has a has a
small footprint but a very high could
have a very high throughput
and the age of covid where you where
your Plastics are sometimes a concern
particularly with tips you don't have to
worry about that because you have that
that one plastic a second handle all
those samples into your hybridization
reaction you cut down reagent costs
you're actually decreasing costs to the
patient to the healthcare system as a
whole
and again you're enabling multiple
throughputs so giving you that
flexibility with that said there's still
a lot more work to be done and we look
forward to continuing our partnership
with miraculous and I just want to take
the moment to thank our partners of
course the ruining a fantastic work as
per usual and thank our partners and say
Al hondro Cassie
um Frank and team for all the great work
that we've done together and we look
forward to continuing it and bringing
some of the Next Generation sequencing
but also Technologies on the road to get
to the patients and with that I'm happy
to take any questions
foreign
for your informative presentation we
will now start the live q a portion
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do them now by
thinking
on the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for let's get started
our first question is uh for Faye have
you tested miraculous marrow canvas with
Kappa products
yes so for the first of all in in the
twist protocol the polymerase uses the
Kappa Hi-Fi so that has been used to
cycle uh for up to 16 cycles of PCR and
then we have also fully automated the
Kappa hyper prep PCR free protocol with
volume reduction down to one third of
what the the kit recommends
right thank you so much
um the next question will be for
Jonathan can you discuss the time and
cost savings achieved by using
miraculous Miro canvas thank you
yes so
um
it's variable it depends on what you do
so right off the bat if you're going
from an apex to a 24 Plex you're saving
for instance what was the cost of eight
samples on the miraculous instrument is
now the cost of 24. so there's reagent
saving there's also a time saving if you
can optimize your lab workflow the
correct way
um maybe saving a day in turnaround so
there is a like I said always thinking
about that all those different variables
and how we get from the start to the end
of the of the road so part of its time
if I had a ballpark and I'd say about
about a 30 percent yeah don't hold me to
that number but I would approximate it
there
great they
question will be for uh Faye
um how can I modify protocol scripts for
example if I want to do additional PCR
Cycles can I add them and how
right there there are there's a web
application where you see the the
protocol steps and there is the ability
to edit within a specific range that we
allow of course uh the the number of PCR
Cycles the duration of incubation steps
um and and also yes the duration and a
number of PCR cycles and the
temperatures within a specific range
great thanks
um another one for for Faye um how how
much customization and tuning is
required to get the mirror canvas to
work for a given application such as the
ont long read or hide capture
so there we we offer uh as you're
showing the list I presented we offer
scripts that are already available and
tested internally we go through a very
thorough reliability campaign before we
release protocols so these are
um press play type of automation now if
there is you know unique to your as I
mentioned earlier unique to your
protocol and incubation step that you
require to spend longer at the center at
a certain temperature or extra numbers
of number of PCR cycles that is
something that you can of course try in
our web application and send a unique
script that uses as a foundation the
existing one that we provided and of
course we have a an excellent team of
field applications scientists that can
guide you through this process although
it's very intuitive and you can do it
even on your own
so to answer the question the the
requirement for optimization is minimal
if uh your uh protocol matches the one
we offer if there are smaller
modifications that can also be
accommodated and and is very quick to
implement
great thank you
um for Jonathan are you using other
methods in parallel with the mirror
canvas or have you moved to the mirror
canvas 100 percent
so the the data you've seen is for for
is in development
um as part of assay Dev it's what we do
is bring on the new products the goal is
of course to have everything fully
automated once it hits the production
lab
um so the goal would be to be fully
there we will always need to validate
manually as a backup because we are a
Diagnostic lab but the least amount of
variability and ways that we can
mitigate any changes in the day-to-day
we always do and again the mirror canvas
and automation as a whole is a way that
we plan on getting there
also real quick I know there was a
previous question about uh cost uh I did
not include
um in my answer cost savings
um of instrument acquisition like if we
were to buy a comparable instrument
um or one of those larger robots a more
traditional instrument it would also
probably be about three to four times
the cost of a of a single miraculous let
alone two or even three
great thank you you
um for Faye
you had a list of protocols that you
developed for the mirror canvas how did
you decide to develop these protocols
so these are requests from scientists
um for example the the language
applications there is definitely a
challenge with with preparing quality
libraries uh with with high molecular
weight input DNA so there are technology
as I explained in in the talk is very
convenient makes the Streamliner process
and doesn't require this expert handling
to maintain the the Integrity of the DNA
throughout the steps thanks to the
very gentle forces electoral wedding
forces that that move the droplets and
and move the DNA from one step to to the
next in the protocol
foreign
could you please discuss the robustness
of e-wedding Technologies particularly
in temperature calibration for thermal
cycling and in the manufacturability of
cartridges
so I start with the second segment of
the question for manufacturability of
cartridges again what I explained how
the cartridges Electronics free has
radically simplified the the QC
steps there and that means that we we no
longer need to worry as previous efforts
had about the the quality of each
electrode uh in the cartridge consumable
because these are now permanently
residing in the instrument uh the the
cartridge is is just films and plastic
it's very uh straightforward to uh to
obtain the the parts and assemble and
when it comes to the instrumentation
there the the calibration for the
temperatures in for example PCR steps or
other incubation steps are done once at
manufacturing and then uh are maintained
throughout the the life cycle of of the
product so we have several customers and
several instruments also internally at
miraculous and have been operating these
uh for a long time now and never had to
to
recalibrate temperatures so that's that
has been very robust
and specifically as as you know for
first for protocols like hybridization
capture that is very temperature
sensitive that's the best uh example
where we have quality output in in the
Target enrichment sequencing metrics
great
um thank you so much
Jonathan a question for you
um you said that you multiplexed 8 16
and 24 samples can you tell us a little
more about The multiplexing Sweet Spot
[Music]
yes
um absolutely so
um
we Multiplex 8 16 and 24. that's what
you have seen we've done other plexing
as well which you have not seen and what
I would say The Sweet Spot really is
correlative to your desired need
and I again just to repeat what I said
it's a matter of actionability versus
cost efficient cost efficiency so if
you're trying to get the optimal cost
efficiency
higher plexing obviously the higher you
go the more cost efficient it is
assuming you don't need to sequence more
there is that that bounce if you're
talking about actionability
um you know speed and good enough to
make a call are what matters most what I
will say is for the optimization of the
plexing temperatures are very important
but also that sweet spot really
correlates also to the size
of your uh
of your panel uh we we mainly work with
small to mid-size panels we're not doing
full exomes or very large panels as such
however the other thing to keep in mind
with these panels is uniformity
um so ensuring that your pull down has
uniform pull down and when I what I mean
by that is that your probes if you're
targeting region a and region B that
your probes are pulling them down
equally
and if you don't have a high uniformity
in your pro pool down the higher you
Plex that lack of uniformity
um will show up in your sequencing
metrics in a negative way so those are
all things to keep in mind
great thank you so much we'll just ask
one last question for Faye how long a
fragments do you think you could work
with on the mural canvas and what about
really long fragments
so in the date I presented our latest
preliminary data from from this news
group we're developing the n50 score is
at close to 78 KB so you can imagine the
the input DNA for for that n50 score to
be achievable is you know above 100 by
KB so I would say we haven't really yet
tested the system with the absolute
longest uh we we are using uh the high
molecular weight extraction uh kids that
are out there so as long as the DNA that
the kit you're using can be extracted
that's what the the input material mural
canvas can operate with so I I I
wouldn't expect there is a limitation
with that
great thank you again Faye and Jonathan
for your time today and for your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots for hosting miraculous
webinar before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions any
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can also be viewed on
demand lab routes will send you an email
when it's available for replay please
feel free to share the email with your
colleagues who may have missed watching
it live take care everyone goodbye